laughs
[Music]
I'm trying to make well I'm starting
with a bicycle helmet and I got these
colored popsicle sticks hopefully it
will be like two Valkyrie wings I have
some spackle that I've dyed with paint
and it's supposed to look like cake
frosting I really like the color it's
very pink and vibrant so I'm happy with
that I've had a stuffed animal penguin
since I was a baby and he's kind of gone
with me through life including college
and he's been there when times have been
tough I guess what I'll miss most are
the people I've met along the way here
at Yale definitely wonderful people a
lot of wonderful people that I met gonna
miss being part of such a Vibrant
Community here
[Music]
foreign